Shan Strickland the UFC guy who smacked
down that woke reporter in Canada who
tried to throw some old tweets or
whatever in his face instead Sean
Strickland stood by his past statements
doubled down on them in no uncertain
terms uh it was great to watch well Dana
White who's the president of the UFC of
course was next up to bat and he was
asked at a press conference a couple
days ago about what sort of leash he
gives his Fighters when it comes to
their free speech you obviously give a
Long Leash to your Fighters about you
know what they can say when they are up
there with a UFC microphone and you are
getting into territory of homophobia
transphobia like is there I don't give
anybody a leash well I'm saying you a
leash control what people say going to
tell people what to believe going to
tell people I don't tell any other human
being what to say what to think and
there's no leashes it was great
fantastic response exactly the right
approach this is why it's so frustrating
when people allow themselves to be
bullied and backed into Corners by these
media vultures